i would like to thank the academy's  board of governors  and the awards committee for granting us  this incredible honor  we're truly grateful this journey  started for me  in 1981 with one simple idea  to make lip syncing replacement dialogue  easier and faster  by letting a computer do the  synchronizing and editing  at various stages the four brilliant  people with me  guy nick john and jonathan  helped turn that idea into reality by  creating hardware versions  and later software plugins our plugins  today  still implement the original idea and  much more  to help audio editors save time and get  better results  lastly i'd like to thank my amazing  colleagues at synchro arts  and my family for their support thank  you  you